okay now let's start with you you are 22
years old I follow you on Instagram how
did you get this following how did you
build this business I mean we were what
started about four years ago as a street
style blog I literally picked up a
camera and taught myself how to use it
and about six to eight months into it I
realized that personal style was a
business I could grow so I turned the
camera on myself and four years later
Here I am how does it make money there's
a few different ways bloggers make money
through affiliate marketing through
sponsored content I mean there's
Instagram content that's sponsored as
well so it really depends what brands
gonna do so Scott who'd Evette on do you
bet on editors of magazine I mean Anna
Wintour has had her position at Vogue
longer than danielle has been alive
I don't follow Anna on and said I don't
even know if she's on insta and I
followed Danielle I mean I know what
wallpaper she's got in her foyer how did
this happen yeah first I mean it's just
super impression you've bet on young
entrepreneurs like yourself but every
time you hear a siren it's a it's a
print Vogue reader read are dying or
someone from a google reader blog being
born so the future is definitely the
pucketts headed towards blogs like that
absolutely but just in terms of their
ability to displace traditional media or
are they able to displace other pieces
of the fashion ecosystem I think the
answer is yes I think that it's gonna
it's gonna have an impact on both your
business is a difficult business because
the CPMs are tougher which forces you to
be more lean what's epns
I'm sorry price per thousand viewers is
typically how that media sold how many
people watch it my guess is you sell ads
the same way here at Bloomberg
television but effectively they're
saying we're selling eyeballs and the
thing about your community that's so
impressive is you've been able to build
content that near the same quality but
for a lot less money so they can operate
much more leanly
than the folks with all the town cars
wrapped around at Conde Nast do you
think of traditional media do you open
the pages of Vogue and Elle and and get
direction yeah I mean I think it's hard
to compare the two because bloggers
represent a real women and a real view
on fashion whereas vogue as you know
more in aspirational view so I think
when you're
lurking at the blogger it's not only the
numbers but it's the demographic is so
specific to the consumer that it really
makes sense for a lot of brands to work
with us but you still love super
expensive high-end thing of course I
mean I try and keep my blog the perfect
mix of relatable and aspirational so I
really love to mix highs and lows
because not all of my followers can
afford you know a $700 pair of shoes so
I like to mix it in with a $20 dress but
couldn't in style say the same thing
sure but I'm so I think with vloggers
your followers have grown to trust you
and specifically as a person they look
to me with what's where so to what
degree do you so you need advertising
obviously right to what degree do you
worry about crossing the line between
editorial independence and becoming
captive to your advertisers I mean with
my blog I'm a part of a platform right
now that handles all my advertisements
so separately from that I worked with I
work with an agency that handles my
sponsored content and you know photo
shoots that I do and stuff like that so
I try and keep it a little bit separate
but couldn't you make the same argument
when one would criticize magazine so
should you say wow these bloggers
they're getting paid you can say the
same thing of any magazine the line was
crossed a long time New York Times is
running neighbor out native advertising
Google the most successful media company
in the world is selling keywords so how
do you okay so then the question is if
you're in Danielle's business how do you
preserve your authenticity in that kind
of a world where you know there are
pitfalls you have great authentic
content which is my senses you have and
you're the readers your readers are
smart readers are smarter than they
think they are as long as you're
transparent this is paid for this isn't
this is not some of the paper content
it's great stuff the New York Times
native content on orange is the new
black show was great and just because it
was paid for it doesn't mean it's not of
interest to people so as long as you're
transparent I'd say no worries how does
a sorry oh no I was just gonna say with
paid content I mean even if a brand was
offering to pay me a lot of money if it
don't if it doesn't truly fit my style I
won't work with the brand so I stayed
true to my style throughout the four
years of doing this and I think my
followers can see that and that's why
they choose to follow and trust me how
does a blogger like
no truly unlock the value for business
does she want to sell it if Anna Wintour
came a-knockin and said you're right you
are the next visionary I want to buy
your business content let me know that I
have been first of all mommy is that
young lots are value well typically
bloggers bring a couple of things they
bring an authenticity a new voice and
they usually bring a younger audience
and no one ever needs a younger audience
no brand ever since says we have too
many 18 to 30 year old fashionable
thought leaders you never hear a brand
say that we need more 75 year olds they
just you don't hear that a lot so you
bring an audience and authenticity and
also you bring a boat this is model your
leaner and meaner how do you scale
Danielle as far as bigger and greater
things right how do you do more right
because ultimately your audience is
going to demand more from you so how do
you do it while making it still then
yell right well I think at this point
with my blog it's more about bigger and
better projects so design collaborations
getting into video I'm working on
writing a book right now which is the
first time I'm announcing it actually so
I mean I think there's just a lot more
and different kinds of parts of the
fashion industry I can get into video
content is a big part of that
the letters talk about fashion week for
a moment because what you're doing is
true street style your overhead is so
tiny look at the millions of dollars
that get spent on this Fashion Week
circus yeah it's crazy but you see a lot
of the smaller brands don't participate
anymore fashion we've gone from B to B
people used to come and actually ride
orders now anyone who's buying can find
the stuff they don't need to come to
Fashion Week but it's become b2c where
it's a platform for a brand new business
to consumer so it used to be actually
riding owners are riding orders now it's
an opportunity for a brand to present
their stuff in a controlled environment
and hope that people like Danielle take
a ton of pictures and spread it to a
much broader audience it's become really
more of a branding and event the thing
that's replaced with smaller brands has
been some of the specialty retailers
like Banana Republic and J Crew are now
doing their own fashion alright yeah
Jake or had their presentation this
morning actually yeah and what did you
see what have you seen that you liked oh
my god I've been to so many shows over
the past four days I'm just yesterday
was Phillip Lim the day before Derek Lam
and they're all top
and it's such an honor to be sitting
front row at some of them can you
believe near 22 years old find anything
I mean I've done I think I've always
grown up pretty young and I I've done a
lot for four years of blogging but
there's always more and I have so much
time to grow that I'm very honored